hello and welcome to life hacks live
we're hanging out with Gary Vaynerchuk
at rise 2017 in Hong Kong Gary welcome
to life acts live we are going to
solicit questions let us know your
questions in the comments below we'll do
our best to get them over to Gary Gary
what we're going to do is take turns
spinning this wheel right here it's
going to land this wheel right here it's
going to land on a corresponding color
okay it's going to be something like
career but it looks like we're starting
off on career obstacles routine have you
and it's a pre-written question so the
discussion is all being driven by this
wheel right here first one career if you
could change one early career decision
what would it be I realized that Google
AdWords were a thing and booked every
key term in the wine business for my
ecommerce store since Wine Library calm
in the beginning the day Google AdWords
started but I didn't spend all the money
on it
it was the foundational piece of the
success of my business in the same way
that eBay and Amazon were actually built
by Google AdWords more than people
realize the big mistake I made was I
kept spending on print and radio and
direct mail I should have taken all the
money and poured it into Google AdWords
my business would have grown from three
incidents set up 3 to 16 it could have
been 3 to 200 but you got some keywords
right early on what was it wine good
wine itself for five cents a click
should have taken more of my money than
it did it was more of me tripling down
on a special moment that was no question
the early career mistake I was right but
I wasn't right enough by going all-in
and now how much does y encaustic four
five six seventy dollars depending on
time of year Wow all right all right
baby let's do this
here we go
routine routine good one what's the
first thing you do when you wake up in
the morning so what time do you wake up
I wake up at 6 o'clock in the morning
and the first thing I do is I grab my
phone and I take it to the bathroom and
I read my news while I take a poop
person it is today even on Sundays even
on Sundays yeah I poop every day but
that's ok ferret but like Sam know
sometimes in the weekend to try to
squeeze in time but like the punchline
being obviously I'm making some jokes is
I will consume my female my tech and my
social engagement for my audience before
anything else that I do before I work
out before I even leave my bedroom where
is your phone when you sleep right next
to me on airplane mode on it is
vibrating island on silent
I am always within arm's reach of my
telephone of every moment of my life
any time you detox one hour two hours
here here honey
yeah when I watched the Munich jets for
three hours I don't care except your
life quitting now yeah no never you know
that I will fully focused i detox when I
do stuff like this I'm focused on this
fare but I don't need a detox for me
because I love it and if I do then up
there was a vacation four years ago
where I put in the state for the whole
week like I'll mix it up I'm not
crippled by the political correctness of
detoxing from technology yet yeah all
right
give it a spin all right we've got
another career so we all have spoken in
2006 and later media Thrillist invite
was at the center of a controversy
because it sought a traveling email and
models only now you immediately
apologized and took two credits or not
credit you think took responsibility at
it but what have you done to prevent
something like that from happening again
I am NOT J being with any other
organization on any event ever again
Gorillaz hired a third party party
presenter they hired somebody else i
mistakingly now went and took
responsibility as a CEO because I didn't
realize how lazy the media was and how
would they would twist that story I had
more respect for the advertising and
business world media and thought they
would do their homework for a second and
realize how little I had to do with that
that was my mistake
and the things I've done to adjust that
is I will no longer JB with other
organizations to throw parties because
there's no reason for me to take a loss
on my column for something that I didn't
have anything to do it is all
controversy good controversy absolutely
not the fact that there are people
running around the world that think that
I would send an invite to attract the
females where business is one of the
most devastating moments in my career
absolutely not I do not believe that all
controversy or attention is good Hitler
has full attention and awareness it's
not for something good so no I don't
believe that all attention is good and
as you can tell by the energy of my
response
it's a disheartening event that I've
learned from and I will not let somebody
else have any impact on my brand if I
can help it all right
all you
obstacle alright what's the biggest
challenge you see for yourself
over the next year I'm crippled by
opportunity and I'm aware by that right
I'm in a place right now where there's
so much being thrown at me from a
personal brand standpoint from a
business standpoint from an investing
standpoint from a life standpoint so the
biggest obstacle right now is being very
good at my yeses and my notes when
you're at a place where you've built for
a long time for all these opportunities
you know now it's going to be my
decision-making and we'll see what
happens you're a storyteller at heart
right no question with so many platforms
and you know Instagram story sort of
snapchat how do you decide every time
you to that phone where it where it
pretty intuitively my mood I like to be
countercultural right now I'm spending a
ton of time on snapchat because I think
people really headlines and thinking
there's not that much attention there
and I have enormous growth there right
now I'm quite intuitive and I like to go
counterculture because its supply and
demand it's applying demand of attention
right and to me I'm always looking for
where places are underestimated and I'm
trying to squeeze out of that oh he
broke the wheel too much energy Gary I
mean let me just tell everybody at home
while he's fixing this he when we got
here is like Gary this is how you spin
it
be very careful I find it very exciting
that he broke the wheel not me
you loosen it up respect okay all right
feel good give it another 90 here we go
when you get your best thank you I get
my best ideas when I'm in the shower or
on an airplane there are two places
where I'm being less hurt especially if
that plane doesn't have Wi-Fi I mean the
truth is your best ideas come when you
don't hear noise and you have a chance
to breathe I never breathe so even on
vacation I struggle to breathe because I
learned for the action and so when I am
forced to breathe non Wi-Fi flights and
the shower literally are the places
where I get my best I never sports
to have that no no I have enough showers
and enough flights with no Wi-Fi that I
don't feel like I have to force it
perfect all right well you pops
you emigrated to the u.s. in the Soviet
Union what challenges did you face and
how has the landscape changed forever
you know look I was four years old so
for me to say I face a lot what I had a
face was not having my dad around you
know he worked every hour when I had a
face was being the first generation only
one born in the old country so the
expectations for me to hustle and grind
and work around the house and take care
of my siblings was pretty high the
biggest one I had to face was I was a
bad student and that's unheard of for
immigrants because education is the way
out I think the landscape has changed
for immigrants the way it's changed for
all of us which is we've never had so
much opportunity the Internet has
created ungodly amounts of opportunity
and so I think immigrants have it better
than ever no matter where they immigrate
because it's not about the establishment
giving them a chance the Internet give
them a chance and so I think the biggest
changes opportunity has grown not
increased and what immigrants have is
humility and work ethic because they're
starting from the bottom often often and
I think that's their biggest advantage
is the u.s. still what it was when you
first came here in terms of the
difference that gap in others
rocks I came in a very funny window we
came in the late 70s when very few
people are actually immigrating to the
US is this different the economy was bad
we came in too late Carter years and
then we walked into the Reagan growth
Europe I think that the you know look it
depends on what kind of immigrant you
are unfortunately there's a lot of hate
and fear in the system right now so if
you are an immigrant from a Middle
Eastern country to the US it's very sad
to say that there are new dynamics that
are challenges to you that are
devastating the great news is and a
small-minded non-educated hate monger
right can't stop you from building your
business
the and I don't know who by the way I
just want to make this clear I'm not
talking about a president I'm talking
about a boss or an educator somebody who
thinks they can stop you nobody can stop
anybody in today's environment so I
would say that it's it's I think it's
better in the US for an immigrant than
it was when I came
I'm top of the cause we're burnin
through this file all right what's one
challenging me every young person should
experience I think every young person
should experience genuine adversity I
think we're living through a terrible
era of parenting where parents are so
micromanaging their children and trying
to protect them from adversity which is
then creating such a vulnerability to
that youth in the reality of the world
so I think every child should experience
getting punched in the face you talked a
little bit about yesterday about
emotional intelligence yes how does one
have high emotional intelligence when
it's so easy right to out of that day
you go on your phone right can you go on
I don't know you know one thing I pride
myself in is talking about things I
understand how we develop emotional
intelligence
I just don't know here's what I can tell
you it really matters and people skills
matter and I'm sure there's ways to
teach young kids examples of empathy and
gratitude I just haven't thought about
it enough to give you a proper answer
all right returns right yep
one more obstacle it's a good one for
you though listen I love awfully close
to here it's way better than balance um
I do not be balanced do not be balanced
truly innovating is easier said than
done
how to keep vaynermedia from running out
of ideas I I think that's very easy all
I have to do is still be the CEO I'm
only in the ideas business I'm only in
innovating I am petrified of my own
success I know that every day that we
have more success is one step closer to
failure like so I am I am in such a
great place on that question I spend all
my time on ideas pretty much all the
time and could never imagine of running
out of them they've been the tried and
true aspect of my 20-year career so as
long as I'm running the business that
will never stop because it is my
religion and you ever find it difficult
to keep your staff hungry the d-roc
compilers how do you make sure that they
don't get you know I'm here a year to
get sort of comfortable by suffocating
by not allowing alternatives like this
is how I trade and by firing if they're
not on board it's a dictatorship like I
will not allow my employees to dictate
the behavior of me that is not strong
leadership and I will not fire them
blindly I'll encourage them and mold
them in the right direction but if they
are not inspired to innovate deliver on
the ideas or come up with their own
they're a vulnerability and they've got
to go and you said yesterday that
culture isn't about feedbag
what suggests reconnect no it is not
about what is it good office culture how
do you do it it's about making everybody
who works for you feel like they're
being heard and that's a very difficult
thing as a matter of fact I have a
vulnerability right now I have an
aggressive open-door policy the problem
is people aren't taking me up on it
because they're scared of taking up my
time or just scared of talking to the
CEO so now I have to adjust I have a
very hardcore plan in 2018 to force
engagement one on one because what I've
been doing for last few years isn't
working only a small percentage feels
heard I need way more to feel heard I
can't rely on them to being heard so now
I have to force it
do another spin maybe we'll get some
balanced leadership all right the new
one
our people board or maze leader what is
that I think they can be born and made I
do think that parents can create a lot
of environments around young children to
encourage leadership but I think that
when they're made they have a limited
upside I think anything that has made
has limited upside I think anything that
is born has ultimate upside and so now
if you were born with it and then you
were made for it you end up being Kobi
good job good obstacles obstacles are
obsessive sig no matter how good I love
this it makes me have fun do you handle
online trolls with empathy and respect
if somebody thinks I'm a jerk or I'm
stupid for I'm wrong I want to
understand why I am blown away by
people's audacity to take anybody that
disagrees with them and call them a
troll and and I do that when people use
vulgar language offend my family I don't
care if they are pushing against me
there's rationale and I want to deploy
empathy and respect which i think has
been a very powerful variable to I've
been successful and it's hard right now
right we're in our own echo chambers our
own of our own life yes
so are you seeing more and more of that
people that don't have empathy
whether you deal with them online or
yeah day to day life well empathy
empathy is a shortage which is why it's
so valuable people don't have enough
self-esteem and respect and patience to
deploy empathy and so yeah I think it's
a very powerful thing spin it yep
routine routine orange how much time do
you spend on social media
how long before sweet candy stuff I
usually stop immediately before sleeping
I probably lose 30 to an hour every
night because I can't get off so I will
always be social right before I go sleep
almost always one quick last glance in
case I miss something
I spend anywhere between 20 minutes
because it was one of those days where I
just had meetings every minute and I
couldn't sneak it in on a travel day
which is half my year I could get
anywhere up to three hours four hours it
runs the gamut you go to bed you wake up
at 6 what's armor seriously go today
midnight that's my range yeah I spit
okay that was a good spin career how
important is good follow-up how
important is social media of young
professionals to build their career does
everyone have a voice no there's a
little no it is social media is enormous
upside enormous upside so not creating
awareness around yourself and your
businesses is a vulnerability however
many people are introverts many people
are better suited just focusing on their
business so I don't think it's for
everyone but it becomes natural to you
if you like to communicate if you have
narcissistic DNA if those things come to
you naturally I'm a very big believer
that you should go all in on it
because all it is is media it's the NBC
I mean it's it's it's propaganda it's
brand building it's awareness it's
imperative it
a long time to crack your own voice no I
uh I'm a big believer in never wavering
from who you are how many people come on
CNBC and talk about pooping in the
morning not many why thank you
I will never waver from telling my truth
and so I committed to that burly and
it's made it very easy for me because I
just lived it's working out it's working
out because I I have skills like I think
it's often forgotten that before I was
Gary Vee I spent a decade building an
actual business before I was Gary Vee I
invested in Facebook Twitter and Tumblr
like I feel like I have merit
I have depth and that matters I think
too many people want to jump into being
22 year old life coaches and I think
that's their vulnerability all right
we're at leader to shed no balance
you've escaped all the balance questions
I don't know how you're doing it what is
the most difficult part about losing a
team especially in today's landscape ah
loneliness when you're a leader you're
lonely and cynicism cynicism mortem
loneliness loneliness sucks but cynicism
is devastating when you're the leader of
something to know who I am in my heart
and to know how hard I tried and to know
how much money I leave on the table
every day to know that there are a
hundred people at vaynermedia right now
that are cynical to me is heartbreaking
cynicism of leaders is not something
you're able to ever get away from
because of the wiring of our fear to
believe in something and to be let down
so cynicism is how do you balance I
don't care what other people think
purses
you know knowing when to care uh by not
caring what people think in the moments
that you allow yourself to go down the
rabbit hole of being worried about
cynicism I mean it's sort of picking and
choosing what's worth caring about
kind of going to the edge and then go in
completely the opposite leg to then
drive your rebalance and recalibration
you know when you're here what most
people do is they try to use the energy
of beer and they only get to hear to me
when I'm here I use this to then bring
it to the minute we're going to give you
a mic for the rest of the session all
right as your mic is it
I think performing wonderfully so Chris
Angela Chan wants to luggage lodging
right now Angela Chan the addiction do
you think it will be an issue for the
coming generation I think Angela that
the establishment and when I see the
establishment I mean old people will try
to make digital addiction a negative and
I think that historically will look back
and realize right now our digital
addiction is a walk in the park compared
to the digital world we're going to live
in and so the robots are going to kill
us there's a big jump from being in your
phone a lot to robots killing us so like
I think yes it will be an issue because
the mainstream media and old people will
try to make it an issue I don't believe
it's an issue
what about robots taking over jobs is
that something that should be a good
robot or younger people taking over jobs
are an issue for people that do jobs
that robots are going to take over like
guys we don't feel bad for the farmers
who lost their jet like people have lost
their jobs forever jobs have been lost
always jobs are always lost so if you do
something I do not feel bad for a truck
driver right now who's 29 years old and
has read a headline somewhere that
speaks to autonomous cars like he or she
knows that in 20 years there's a very
good chance that trucks are going to
drive themselves he or she are more than
capable in four hours a day educating
themselves on another skill if they
choose to put their head in the sand and
be an ostrich they should cease the same
fate that everybody who's put
their head in the sand has faced which
is losing alright I'm going to give it a
spin let's go for that obstacles I think
this is the last obstacle
what's an obstacle you faced that made
you better at what you do today all of
them like I mean every loss like the
obstacle right now that I'm pissed that
nobody takes me up on my open-door
policy
so I'm going to react to it and I'm
going to force every employee to see me
every six months period end of story
I will see them all every employee
that's right New York Island in whatever
it takes I will give up all the time I'm
going to give up five minutes five
minutes times 800 lots of it why do you
think it is do you think you mentioned
people I think they need an empathy for
me and they think I better things to do
than here they're five minutes of the
headaches I don't think they realize
that I want to fix every problem I think
they think I'm like every other one of
their managers in the building that
can't fix every problem so they don't
want to hear it I can fix them all and
then others and then I think cynicism
and fear and lack of self esteem and
they think I care more about being Gary
Reed and Gary Vaynerchuk the CEO there's
a million reason I don't care what the
reasons are I need to fix my concept
that's a adversity that will make me
better and that happens every single day
there's been reports that the average
person spends 1.7 seconds per post on
Facebook I'm a bore scrolling to the
next one right okay so James is asking
how do you stand out when people get so
accustomed to that quick scroll my
understanding that people spend 1.7
seconds and then good giving all your
effort to the picture to the preview
screen to the copy and respecting the
1.7 seconds not saying I'm so funny I
can post this video on Facebook and it's
going to work out it's about respecting
the medium and the consumer I spent an
ungodly amount of time worrying about
the preview image the copy the time I
posted who I posted the first word does
another dime you've had a very busy year
expanding to planet of the app yes I'm
doing a lot of big things share wants to
know what's the next venture for Gary
Asia strategy it's very much wrong
you've been very busy I'm not here by
accident so I think Asia strategy for me
is a very big 2018 thing rippling down
on the tweaks to make vaynermedia the
ultimate agency in the world and and
probably audio I'm obsessed with Alexis
skills Google home Apple home pod my
podcast audio is an obsession of mine
wonderful give it a spin let's try and
get that balance in there
come on obstacles god damn it there's no
more obstacles - you conquered all the
obstacles Gary as a CEO yeah I'm going
to skip this one okay as a CEO do you
ever switch off if so we're already
established Gary doesn't switch off on
social idea when do you draw a line
between personal and professional
- blurred because I'm in full control
that is not for everybody at home I
respect that you have bosses so you have
to be more careful when I make mistakes
I lose business when other people make
mistakes they get fired very different I
would say that you have to reverse
engineer your organization some are
conservative some are not and to me you
have to draw the line based on the
reality of your business not how you
want it to be but how it actually is
because Mark Zuckerberg talks about that
a lot right he says gone are the days of
your work persona your personal persona
your ceremony you have one four can I
listen that's fine for Mark Zuckerberg
but I disagree with them on that because
a lot of people have to play in the
frameworks because they work in
organizations that still dictate to them
that they have to have a personal and a
professional profile but it's getting
harder to hide right just because you're
wearing a tie in your LinkedIn profile
if you go to Vegas and throw up on
everybody people are going to know
Marcel asks what is the best advice you
can give to this generation that hard
work is a requirement for anything that
is successful
this notion i love when kids email me
Gary B you always talk about hustle and
hard work but I work smart not hard for
our work week right Tamara
listen for our working I'll get to that
in a minute my answer to that is like
that's great Rick I work smart and hard
now how are you going to beat me right
for work week it's an amazing title and
Timothy genius but if you really
carefully he's just talking about being
efficient where where you can be
efficient so you can devote Tim Ferriss
is one of the hardest-working guys I
know so I think 4-hour workweek
oftentimes because of its title speaks
to working smart and not hard for a work
week Turk speaks of being efficient for
automating AI or assistants or why are
you wasting time in this so that's how I
see 4-hour work week all right
let's get another question in there and
routines how many uh how many hours of
sleep do you get we around six how much
time do you spend it traveling how much
fine do it time do I spend traveling I
probably travel a hundred times a year
and right and I don't travel and I spent
all my time with my family in the
weekend so there's not about 250 days
then vacations you're talking about 220
days like almost in theory almost half I
for offices London I like Chattanooga
Tennessee I do a lot of public speaking
as strategic ventures into Helmand
I'm not coming I didn't speak here
because I mean I love speaking and when
I speak I don't because of the speaking
speed I speak because what is the impact
on my businesses I'm looking to
establish an office in Asia I want to
build brand equity to the environment
that's why I'm here and I'll go and
speak at a conference where there's 500
CMOS because I want it to be business
development for my organization so I'm
very strategic about my travel and I
want it to all 94 percent of it is
lending itself to the growth of
vaynermedia which is my focus right now
last question what is the question you
wish
laughs on podcast on life hack slide
that they're not asking honestly this
question gets brought up sometimes and
I've always struggle with it but I
actually think now I finally know how to
answer it I want them to ask me the
question that they want to ask when
you're an answer of questions you don't
get to choose two questions you just
have to answer them but is there is
there something people aren't talking
about that she looks like that every
single thing I mean you know the answers
and you know forget about the question
you know what I wish was going on people
actually did something with my answers I
mean you know I am creating enormous
amount of winners I could create a lot
more of them if people stopped watching
me for entertainment and motivation and
started doing something with what I'm
giving them that's the great notes to
leave it off on I like a cheap right
sure well thank you so much I apologize
about that audio no it was actually a
benefit I prefer it in the future CNBC
good to know next time all right thanks
for tuning in